i did have this feeling where i was like
you know movies are fine to make a
little money but i can't really
i don't love them and then i got the
script for stranger things
and i had this moment where i
read that script and i was like this is
beautiful and this character is
beautiful and
if they want me to play this character
there'd be no way i could
cynically show up and sort of just like
coast through it
[Music]
stranger things i had always been a guy
in movies who was like like six or seven
on the call sheet
uh real supporting player and i usually
was the guy with the gun
who was running after denzel or liam
neeson or whoever it was
you know either a cop or a villain or
whatever and
it was hard to put your heart into that
stuff
after a while because you're seen a
certain way you're edited together as a
certain way
and it just becomes a two-dimensional
thing and i always you know got into
acting
to really create three-dimensional
characters and on stage i could still
create those characters
you know there was even a moment where
there was a big movie that they wanted
me to play like
seven on the call sheet and i i was like
no i want to go do shakespeare in the
park you know
and then people they couldn't believe it
they sort of hollywood can't believe
when you turn them down so
i um but i did have this feeling where i
was like
you know movies are fine to make a
little money but i can't really
i don't love them and then i got the
script
for stranger things and i
had this moment where i read that script
and i was like this is beautiful
and this character is beautiful
and if they want me to play this
character
there'd be no way i could cynically show
up
and sort of just like coast through it
and then once i got it and i started
working on it
i found even more so if i
was really going to play this character
i had to just like put my whole self
into it
in a way that was different and up until
that point
i had understood that hollywood
or movies were certainly about you know
kind of how good you look
i don't have a lot of the components of
that person and
that person hasn't got me very far
anyway
it's not like at 20 whatever i was chris
hemsworth
so good looking and strong and you know
fierce that i was given these roles i
was kind of a guy who was they were kind
of like yeah
even when you're you know sort of good
looking and in shape like
we're not that impressed with you and so
i was like all right
i may as well because the one thing i
can do is like i can act
and i was like i may as well just like
throw my soul into this thing and
i let myself go like i'm just gonna eat
donuts like this guy would do and like
go into this semi depression with this
kind of clownish joie de vie that he has
through that anger i started smoking
cigarettes and i was just like i'm just
gonna play the hell out of this guy
like and then i thought i'll be you know
i'll be done and i'll go back and just
do plays
and then it became like a huge success
and i was like oh wow
i can't put my heart into things and
that rejuvenated my experience of film
and tv
where i was like oh yeah you you can
tell
narratives that are important that are
three-dimensional david you can do this
and that was a beautiful experience for
me and
life-changing and then l she just
slams the door right in my face
uh-huh you know it is that smug son of a
[ __ ]
mike he's corrupting her i'm telling you
and i'm just gonna lose it i mean i'm
gonna lose it joyce just take it down
hopper i need for them to break up that
is not your decision
they're spending entirely too much time
together
my relationship to children in general
has changed
and i think it's partially as a result
of playing this character
of hopper but also as a relation in
relation to them
one of the things i love about them so
much is just that there's actually kids
like
they're great actors as well but
especially that first season they were
so awkward and unaware of themselves
i remember finn in particular would just
like do this thing with his body that
only kids can do
like we're all so we understand cameras
are on us but kids are still
i don't know what's going on i mean i
forget what it's like to be a kid but
it's just like you can't really control
your body um and i love that about them
that spontaneity and that purity and
naivete in the beginning i really tried
to stay away from them because i felt
like hopper has a
distant relationship with these kids and
as the series went on even the first
season especially into the second
i started to fall in love with them and
they really do feel like my family
and watching them grow up i was scared
in the beginning
you know they got so famous and the
papers
do all kinds of things and now
i'm so proud of all of them in terms of
their
deft navigation of that world
and it was incredible to watch along the
pro along the way i mean one of the
funniest
sweetest things was after the first
season
finn wolfhard showing up in season two
and like
trailing the duffer brothers around with
headphones
wanting to direct an episode that season
i was like
man that's like a 14 year old kid you
know
and he was earnestly wanted to direct an
episode of stranger things and i was
like
yeah that'd be amazing i'm not going to
let you give me any notes finn but yes
i would love to see you direct an
episode what i wanted
to say to you is that um
oh i think we're in trouble
so yeah i've been you know i've been
really proud of them and it is this
special relationship because
they i occupied a time in their lives
that is so
profoundly you know big like they were
11 to now they're like 17
18 and that period of your life is so
big
and so i think i occupy a special place
in their lives as well
you know what your mom called
what yeah
she needs you home right away is
everything okay
no i don't think so i do feel like when
they show up on set they're like
hey david like i do feel like there's a
certain
you know fear uh respect of me
that i no longer exploit i used to
i just like that we have that place in
each other's lives
hellboy
hellboy was an interesting experiment
for me i still get a lot of love online
you know in little dms and little ways
for that movie which i really like now
because the time it came out it was very
poorly received and you know it hurt
because no matter what you're doing
whether it's received well or badly i
think you throw your whole
self into it we were well intentioned in
trying to
make you know a new version of hellboy
that was
um as good as it could be and not being
compared to that unfortunately we were i
sat down with ron i loved
what he did in those movies i loved
those guillermo del toro movies
and we just wanted to try something
different i thought there was supposed
to be
three
oh
there was a lot of stuff that was left
on the cutting room floor in terms of my
work on that i mean
i did a lot of work that we didn't
ultimately use i
wanted it to be very very different and
it
you know whatever the constraints were
around me that didn't want that to be
i mean i had all these things based on
language where
you know hellboy's natural tongue is
demonic
in fact there are things like
that i felt like word demonic tongue and
then you know people that
learn language learn english and later
age like what those people are
i had all this like intricate detailed
character work
and dance
like a prophecy
the most interesting thing about the
whole experience for me
i watched frank langella talk on a
documentary about
being skeletor in the he-man movie
back in the 80s which i think is the 80s
if you haven't seen the he-man movie it
is
quite an interesting movie and franklin
deal is covered in prosthetics and
you know just just it's it doesn't hold
it's not a good movie
but he he worked with joseph campbell
unlike the mythology of that and then
coming up with the line and he loved
skeletor he
loved that character so much i have sort
of a similar experience to what happened
with us with hellboy
it was like i think the movie's fun but
it
our vision and our our passion for it
was very high
and then you know uh life winds up
giving you what life gives you
so uh it was interesting it's all i
could really say
how do you have hair on your tongue
[Music]
black widow
yeah i just loved it i love red guardian
i love black widow i love that whole
world
it's sort of a combination and a
culmination of all these other things i
mean
you have the enormity of the project
which is this marvel
universe world where the sets are the
best possible sets
everything's just stunts everything is
just the best of all worlds and then you
put at the heart of it kate shortland
who is really
an indie very creative director who
in the past has told some good stories
about women coming of age
and um and that was a beautiful
juxtaposition
still fits family
back together again you got fat
smelly water we had a lot of discussions
about red guardian
there there's a lot of complexity there
i mean he is really kind of a silly guy
but even
the guilt around his own narcissism and
how he did
fail his children is
interesting and kind of comes through in
the movie i also like the fact that i
got
really fat for it and there's my
favorite shot in the movie is like i'm
running out of this prison and
and my belly is moving like this in
front of me like a
bag of ferrets so that
it's not my own take but uh yeah
revolutionary road movies
still felt to me like a very foreign
world um
i had no plans to do them my heart was
really in new york theater and i thought
that that was where i would be accepted
as well and the fact that i was accepted
was like a dream come true i mean that's
all i really wanted to do it's all my
ambition was
the interesting thing was virginia woolf
actually sort of led to the screen
career sam mendes saw me
in that play and called me in when he
was
looking to put together the cast for
a revolutionary road and it was
one of the most incredible moments of my
life because i was just this theater
actor in new york you know done a little
a little bit of film but i was certainly
not known in any way
and my agent told me i had a meeting
with sam mendes and i went in
and i knew the book very well it was
like
one of my favorite books um and i said
you know amazing that you're doing this
movie but i hope you don't mess it up
because it's a really beloved book
and he said yeah i hope i hope we don't
too you're the
only person i can think of in this role
and i was like what like i was like who
am i like i'm just some guy in new york
like doing play
i mean i can't believe out of all the
actors you could cast into kate wins the
leonardo dicaprio movie that i'm like
the only guy who think of in this role
we're going to europe
to paris
to live when
in september but what for because we've
always wanted to because the
the kids are young enough because it's
beautiful i mean really i mean chef
you've been there
you tell her yeah it's a great city
throughout the years my process has
developed
a lot and that production in particular
was really kind of a blur because i was
so
out of my element i had only known kate
winslet and leonardo dicaprio as being
like a fan of these big
huge movie stars and so there i was like
in scenes with them um it was very
you know confusing i was sort of
terrified
uh so what are you gonna do frank well
i'm gonna study and i'm
gonna read i suppose i'm gonna
finally figure out what i want to do
with my life shep while she supports you
yes but my process in terms of starting
to work on him was that he had been a
former military guy
and he prided himself on that before he
got lost in the suburban
world and so even talking with the
costume designer
i was like what would he be drawn to in
a shirt in the shop if he was and
i thought he'd be drawn to more military
type things and so
we had like pockets on his shirt just
little touches like that
because he really does have this life
that he has with these kids and this
wife who
and then he has this fantasy life with
her which is about
paris and you know it talks about the
way she smells like i think it's like
fresh linen and lemons or something i
mean
what kind of man is going to sit around
his bathrobe all day picking his nose
while his wife goes out and works no
shep
i just don't know
why are you crying and then there are
moments where i mean
shep even in his name to me it evokes a
puppy
it evokes like a dog and and i think
there were elements of that animal
kind of in him this sort of faithful dog
who could get very angry and could also
be naive and puppyish in a certain way
i played with that with kate
april
this is what i've always wanted
i love you don't say that
the other great thing about him is he
just would reveal his inner monologue
and there was even a scene where i walk
out and i look over after my kids treat
me like garbage and i
walk out and i look over our hill to
their house
in the book he just sits there and he
says i love you but
i love you and he just repeats it
and so beautiful like he's almost
practicing how he's gonna say it
in the movie they cut that out and it's
just him staring
but we shot all that so
you know there was a lot of like
a lot of playing around with these
different elements
i
broke back mountain that was really
a very early movie for me again and it
was something where i didn't really
understand the medium as well
i had known jake gyllenhaal a little bit
you ever notice how a woman will powder
her nose before she goes to a party
and she'll powder it again once the
party's over
and wipe out your nose just go home go
to bed
oh no he sort of understood that another
much so he would sort of provoke me in
various ways to help me understand
film in that way we'd be moving on and
he'd say things like ask for another ask
for another and i'd be like
what do you mean the director said he
got it he's like no ask for another you
want to
just ask him he's got a little uh cabin
down on lake camp
got a crappie house a little boat said i
could use it whenever i want
we ought to go down there some weekend
drink a little whiskey fish son
it was a little scene so there wasn't a
lot to go on but there was so much
sort of packed in that scene you know
the short story itself was so rich
i thought the movie was so beautiful and
it really wasn't about
dialogue it was about these little
moments that aang would
create and allow to happen you could
tell that the movie was built on all
these delicate
little moments as opposed to big scenes
with lots of dialogue
and you felt that when you read it so it
didn't matter that there wasn't a lot
for randall it felt very potent
get away you know
i feel like right from the very
beginning they can tell that they both
have these needs
and even sitting on that bench was like
a wonderful way to
be there with the other character and
just feel this need and ang really let
us
you know play that i mean when we shot
it it was very
relaxed in terms of how the lines played
out or what happened
and we could really just sit there and
sort of take each other in and take in
the importance of this moment
quantum of solace
quantum was a whole other level in movie
making that i'd never
been a part of the budget was like 200
million
showing up in london
at pinewood and it was called b-22 at
that time it was the 20-second bond
movie
they have their own stages their own
thing i went and i saw there's a set in
some sewer with the cart i mean just the
sets were so magnificent and huge in the
detail
i'd never really seen anything like it
and that but you know even in the
magnitude of this the first day i got
there
i talked to mark forest director who i
just loved uh
because he was such a indie director in
this huge sandbox
and had such love for even you know a
smaller character like greg beam
and really wanted me to play around but
the first day i got there it was just
judy dench behind glass
like doing this monologue like it was
like three pages or something just
talking to bond on the phone
as she was behind this like computerized
glass i think
oh hi this is gregory hello mr beam
uh i'm so sorry to keep you waiting we
have no interest in mr green
thank you he's a person of extreme
interest
the great thing about it was that mark
was such an indie director so he was
really in it for
the creativity and you know the silly
moments especially with a character like
this greg beam character
we played around with lots of different
things i mean i think at one point too
there's a lot of stuff on the cutting
room floor that mark and i just improv
because it's like
you know it's a james bond movie we're
not gonna like sit around with this
you know cia guy greg beam for a long
time but there were
there was a party that jeffrey wright
and i go to we go to the villains like
party at one point and i think i went up
to some lady and was like uh b
greg b like you know we're playing
around with stupid stuff like that
even though like fly i think this
actually is in the movie but there's a
moment where
uh jeff and i are talking and he's gonna
go meet bon
and i had a fly swatter mark was like
wouldn't it be great if you had like a
fly swatter and you could just like you
know and that was like a fun little
thing like that
so do we have an understanding uh yeah
we do nothing to stop a coup in bolivia
in exchange the
new government gives america the least
standing oil found
if it's oil you want we didn't find
diamonds did you
but yeah it was just this mega movie
that i had this minor role in but he
really
invested a lot and made him this
silly uh intricate version
of i feel like of america to the brits
like you have this
super you know sexy british
spy who's got it all together and you
know even jeffrey wright on the lower
level of the american cia is like you
know helping him out and then like at
the top of the
chain is this kind of you know boorish
very loud drunk and confident
guy you don't need another marxist
giving national resources to the people
do you
well we can hardly be expected to do
something about a coup we know nothing
about
i think the absurdity of all that was
was fun to play the newsroom
[Music]
elliott was great i really liked doing
the newsroom
the problem that i had with the newsroom
was that everyone was so intelligent
in the newsroom and had such integrity
and
i kept fighting for elliott to be the
guy who had no integrity and was
not that bright but unfortunately sorkin
would give me lines still that
belied my intelligence although i think
as the show went on he started to
give me less of those lines there's a
race for state rep in hutchinson kansas
that defies cliche
the democratic incumbent jan paul's is
anti-gay gay marriage
a gay person anti-gay tonight jan paul's
faces off against a republican
challenger who's a pro-choice pro-gay
rights railroad conductor named dakota
bass
there's no way i'm not spending the
entire night talking about this race
i am i called it you mean you called it
i just told you about it did you call it
i'd no i did call
okay you know one of the most
interesting things is even the best
newscasters out there the walter
cronkites of our time
on whatever network it is you watch cnn
or fox news or whatever all those guys
i mean a lot of the guys i've met and
talked to are
underneath the table you know texting
their friends
silly jokes i wanted ellie to have that
like i wanted him to be really
interested in his twitter followers
and interested in his brand and i liked
that aspect in a show
where so many of the people were
interested in the integrity of you know
broadcasting and the integrity of
you know journalism i wanted the
the other side of it which is that
there's a lot in
journalism that is entertainment and
that is um
not well intentioned by any means and is
uh narcissistic and and i really wanted
to
play that uh and i think i got some of
that in there and
aaron you know was interested in some of
that but in general it was a show
sort of like the west wing aaron's very
interested in this
almost idealized version of people with
a lot of integrity in politics and in
journalism and
i also see a different brand of person
in politics and journalism and i
really wanted to do that so i did as
much as i could but uh
but yeah it wasn't a lot this is what
i'm talking about women
and closets what about men in showers
i've got an awesome shower i love my
shower where's she keeping her clothes
in the meantime
my closet or are you keeping your
clothes the shower oh dude
aaron is a brilliant guy and
he's a guy who clearly in college would
write his papers
right before they were due because there
would be days where
i think i would talk to him too we'd
have a table reader because
you know how's it going you table read
in two days or something
like that's good i got to go home and uh
you know write 70 pages of the script
but it's but it's good
great man good luck with that and you
know i think we even did have like
a week or two of shutdowns while he was
working
but i mean i have a lot of sympathy for
that because i even look at
the duffer brothers and stranger things
now or look at aaron
and it really is a singer he did have a
writer's room and they contributed a lot
but it really is
a very singular voice his shows and his
movies and so
he is doing a lot of the writing and
it's incredibly hard to write
simply a one hour of a television show
but to produce eight to ten
episodes twelve episodes of a television
show is like
it's just really hard so i have a lot of
sympathy for that and they also were
very intense
the script supervisors and the producers
were very intense about
your saying of the dialogue exactly as
the dialogue was written and that's a
unique thing
a lot of shows and movies i work on
they'll be like yeah if you say
something
generally along those lines like
we're good it's one like i had a mini
monologue early on and it was something
like you know it's like half a page
like me like going at this thing and
then we did a take and the script
supervisor came over and she was like
it's
um it's not someone it's somebody
and i was like man in the middle of the
speech like you just want me to focus on
like someone somewhat so
i mean it was very technical in that way
it was they were very
they loved his words and he didn't want
you to change a single one of them the
musicality was a part of it so
that was very unique to that particular
production
end of watch that movie
in particular was a nutty experience
for all of us i think the movie turned
out
very well to the credit of david ayer
and also jake really threw himself
into it one day the lapd is going to
bend you over your black and white and
they are going to [ __ ] you
up the ass they are going to [ __ ] you
so long and so hard
you're going to want to eat your gun
just to make it stop and if
if you don't eat your gun and the
somehow magically stops
they're going to give you freeway
therapy we did a lot of police
training we really um
went deep into this cop world we did
we did also did the you know the pt type
stuff that they do
when they're recruits we also got
tasered
as all police recruits do they get
tasered and pepper sprayed so they know
what it
feels like we didn't get pepper spray
but we got tasered and i will tell you
that is a very unpleasant experience
you kids have fun out there the lapd has
got a big
you got a big heart thank you for
sharing that
can't wait to get it up the air in a
sense it probably adds to the flavor of
the movie and also there were real gang
members a lot of the actors were real
gang members that
uh david sort of you know knew in a
certain way
a lot of the cops in the movie are real
cops and there's a certain value
to to that in terms of my particular
process
there was little value um i think there
is a
metaphoric aspect to what we do that
really
does not translate to real life i mean
there's a great like stoppard quote
in rosacea guildenstern where the head
actor comes out and says we're actors
we're the opposite of people
and i do feel like it's kind of true
like me walking around as a policeman
what i'll bring to it is something
personal from my life that can
metaphorically relate to the policeman
but me actually doing police stuff
i can understand in a certain way but
going too deep into it doesn't make much
sense because
i don't have a relationship to policing
in that way
would you uh call for a rescue don't
move do not move what do you look like
where'd he go
northbound through the houses hispanic
male
blue checkered shirt it's just a weird
thing where sometimes
directors and productions get into the
realism of things so
much that we they lose sight of the fact
that
i have no relationship to that
particular realism what i have
relationship to is my personal
metaphoric relationship to that in
certain ways it's useful to understand
procedure
but it's really about a scripted
character
and so there's a weird
play of those things that didn't the
deeper you go into it the less sense it
makes
[Music]
the equalizer this is a
an example of a heightened movie as
opposed end to watch really went for
a kind of realism that um
i sort of feel is better served
in the documentary realm so equalizer is
you know based on a tv show it it has
entertainment value
it's kind of broader in its paint
and its palette of color and i enjoyed
that
um and yeah frank masters
was more of a character in that way
once you get out of here go [ __ ]
yourself you
father you know what you're dealing with
huh
i am a cop you [ __ ] i loved antoine
fuqua
i loved him and i really also
i didn't get to know him as well but i
really liked denzel
and i really learned a lot from denzel
on that movie i learned a lot
that i brought with me into stranger
things to be honest about a leading role
in a film
there was a stillness that he had all
right all right all right
whoa
in terms of masters
he was really fun and wild to play
i mean he was just like a loose cannon
one of the great things about antoine
too is there's just tons of improv
so most of the stuff that is mine in the
movie is improv the whole scene with me
and denzel where he
he's handcuffed me and i'm yelling at
him was that was all that wasn't even in
the script
and i even said antoine after he shot it
i was like that's not going in the
movies
going into the movie i was like okay you
know what [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
you have [ __ ] me so bad you did this
you [ __ ]
yourself you did it disrespected is bad
you understand me
and also that character was an exercise
in how many times and how many different
ways i could say the word
antoine would say to me you go like oh
man it's like musical when you say i'm
like you
you don't found it
just as many times as i possibly could i
really like that
as well it was fun